DC Comics Liam Neeson isn't killing
anyone in this scene you may find what
you were looking for in the first place
particularly if what you're looking for
just happens to be a ninja training
facility I know it's early an Alfred's
butlering career but he completely
forgets to shut these doors back here so
we build a niche public transportation
system to unite the city and at the
center
Wayne tower citizens of Gotham here's a
railroad and never forget who gave you
that railroad yeah let's take my son who
is deathly afraid of bats - his first
opera featuring bats richest family in
the city exits the Opera House through
the graffiti ridden side door into an
alley take it easy
yeah just chill am i right chill get it
okay moving on good news your parents
are alive we got him
oh it was nothing that you did yeah it
was he wanted to leave a boring opera
early that's what happens when you don't
support the Arts nipple bed a flashback
within a flashback do you think if Bruce
could do an inception inside his
flashbacks he'd be able to warn his dad
to avoid dark alleys Katie Holmes after
the hearing where Jill gets shot it goes
from obvious midday to Twilight at about
three minutes alone fear before I cry
and through success where did you learn
to kick so much ass that prison guards
are putting you in solitary to protect
the prisoners are you able to beat ass
because you're angry it gives you
exactly the same powers as mr. furious
[Music]
it is beyond saving and and once we take
care of Gotham all evil in the world
will vanish this is definitely not Liam
Neeson so I guess Liam Neeson isn't
doing anything in this scene see Alfred
when you leave the door wide open you
get bats inside the house it takes 53
minutes for Batman to begin I mean I
guess all we're really supposed to know
is the Batman is hitting these people
and kicking their asses if we were meant
to know the specifics of the fight I'm
sure they'd show him to us come on if it
wasn't required for the plot there's no
way the assistant DA in a city this size
would be writing the sleazy subway
trains home late at night and if she did
she wouldn't live in an area that
required her to get off the subway at
rape alley no one takes the law into
their own hands in my city yeah but
people certainly break the law in their
own hands in your city but sure focus
all your efforts on the guy dressed as a
bat
[Music]
buying a hotel is as simple as stuffing
a check into a hotel staffers pocket and
requires no contracts Batman doesn't
kill King Joffrey when he has a chance
old data files backup discs on my desk
good luck getting into poor knowledge
you just asked for on your desk now that
you've fired his ass the town's water
supply would definitely not run under a
building and the water would not keep
flowing through the pipe like this if
there was a big gaping hole in it okay I
take back everything I said about Katie
Holmes at least tell me what it looks
like you know what it looks like asshole
you were the one on the roof of the
parking garage telling Batman to turn
the engine off stay with me does Rachel
see the same horrifying oil leaking
bat-diamond when Batman talks to her
just like scarecrow did Batman is a dick
to everything the effects of this poison
are always changing Bruce went into a
coma Falcone went crazy scarecrow goes
crazy but somehow I become sane hours
later without the antidote and where
rachel gets her dose suddenly she's in
danger of dying this poison needs to
make up its mind as to what it does to
people they put it all in mr. Davis for
weeks this poison has been in the city's
water for weeks and no one has reported
psychedelic effects after boiling the
water or using a vaporizer party guests
sing happy birthday long before any of
them could have known Bruce was about to
enter the room either that or they've
been standing here singing it for hours
just waiting for his arrival unless you
have a microwave emitter powerful enough
to vaporize all the water in the mains
yet another ridiculously complicated bad
guy plan let's take the water supply
with poison which has to be inhaled for
it to work then on the off chance
there's a powerful machine that turns
the city's water into vapor we can get
the whole city hallucinating in no time
you're never short of a few freeloaders
how does Bruce win back any friends
after this speech wouldn't vs. name
forever be tainted is the crazy guy who
told his friends to fuck off and burned
his own house to the ground
yep in the next movie he's got enough
friends to throw a fundraiser for Harvey
Dent because people love him some Bruce
Wayne also never go to a Bruce Wayne
party she always goes down
without even looking Ross knows that a
random beam on fire is about to fall on
Bruce before it actually falls my house
so left me for dead
consider escena it's not even remotely
even heat burned your house but then
dragged your body out of the burning
house saved it from falling off a cliff
and then left you with a villager to
nurse you back to health
Ra's al Ghul is a dick these members of
the League of Shadows a group of
extremely skilled vigilante ninjas are
taken out by an old man with the golf
club this cop lets Rachel into the
Narrows without checking ID of any kind
also I take back my take back about
Katie Holmes she's probably fucking your
uncle Jamie Rachel just happens to
stumble onto the one group of cops that
are actually bad guys as well as the
same little boy Batman had a moment with
earlier holy coincidences Batman now
scarecrow just happens to come across
Rachel in a foggy mist also how did
scarecrow hear what Rachel said to King
Joffrey Wow Batman knew exactly where to
glide through all this smoke after
saving Rachel in the kit the monorail
follows water maze the central hub
beneath Wayne tower precious moving lung
domains will be waste time with an old
man giving a sex position already
delivered by Batman earlier can you
really knock down this many support
columns without the entire building
coming down I mean if you can what's the
point of having the support columns in
the first place mysterious super weapon
conveniently self-destructs after the
train accident somehow early isn't
informed about all the changes at Wayne
Enterprises before he walks in the door
I guess Bruce managed to keep the whole
board and the entire media from telling
him so that arrow could get an amusing
and embarrassing comeuppance using the
same words he used against Bruce and Fox
didn't you get the memo never stopped
thinking about you about us
and I found out about your mask jeez
what a cocktease what happened to your
balls drop off get out the devil there
practice
I mean listen we talking about practice
not a game not a game not a game be
talking about practice what are you
sitting I have come here to chew
bubblegum and kick ass don't even think
of that try escape